So the answer here is, there are already 120 possibilities to visit 5 houses.
The way you calculate this is there are 5 possibilities for the first house,
times 4 possibilities for the second house,
times 3 for the third one, times 2, times 1.
So it's the same as a factorial of 5,
if you are familiar with that terminology, which is 120.
For the second one, the number in different ways of which you can visit 10 houses,
it's a factorial of 10, which is precisely 3,628,800.
As you can see this number here grows enormously.
Just to give you one more example.
If we were to visit 15 houses, then the number of possibilities would be 1,307,674,368,000,
which, as I'm sure you'll agree, is quite a lot. Even for a computer to handle.